Working for the Waimakariri District Council
is rewarding, with competitive salaries,
highly active social groups and strong career advancement opportunities.
We're focused on serving our community, and
when you build a team of over 300 dedicated,
qualified and friendly people - you can be
sure goods things are going to happen.
The staff have a great relationship with councillors
and community board members and we're all here
for the same purpose, and that is to make
Waimakariri a great place to be
in partnership with our communities.
Waimakariri District is just 15 minutes north
of Christchurch.
Our district combines the best of town and
country, with the urban centres of Rangiora,
Kaiapoi, Oxford and Pegasus, large productive
rural areas, costal settlements
and small rural townships.
It is also one of the fastest growing districts
in the country and that variety and challenge
makes the WDC an exciting place to be.
A lot of the work we do is unseen.
Sewerage, water, community support
building the foundations a
growing community thrives on.
We design the parks, build the roads,
maintain the pools
and we plan for the future of our district.
And we’re good at it.
Our award- winning teams are respected in
their fields and have a wealth of experience
to share with those starting their careers.
Council has been really supportive to me,
in training, experience and mentoring to become
a chartered professional engineer.
Frequent social events, friendly co-workers
and advancement opportunities all make our
council an excellent place to set up a long
term career.
I've had all sorts of opportunities, from
professional development right through to
new job opportunities, that have been able
to grow and enhance my skills and let me do
new things around the community.
However for a lot of us, perhaps the greatest
satisfaction comes from helping to build a
district that people are proud to call home.
I love that I get to come to work every day
and work with fun and energetic people who
really like to make a difference in our community.
So if you want to work with us in making Waimakariri
a great place to live
visit our recruitment page
waimakariri.govt.nz/careers